an einem von sieben orten in unserem
sonnensystem finden wir bald
außerirdische davon ist der alien
forschers estos hat überzeugt warum das
so ist und wo genau das sein könnte
jetzt im blick zum treppchen wie ist die
lage bei den außerirdischen und wann
entdecken wir intelligente aliens
herzlich willkommen seit 2001 leitet
schostag dass sie die projekt also das
projekt bei dem gezielt nach
außerirdischen gesucht wird search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
seti-institut heißt das institut also
institut für die suche nach
außerirdischem leben wti macht das in
dem es systematisch radiosignale aus dem
weltall analysiert 2007 hat es dafür
sogar ein eigenes teleskop array
aufgebaut sie allen telescope array
benannt nach dem microsoft mitbegründer
und multimilliardär paul allen der es zu
einem großen teil finanziert hat das
sind 42 teleskope die ausschließlich
nach aliens suchen die auf exoplaneten
weit entfernt von unserem sonnensystem
existieren doch der leiter des instituts
schostag vermutet jetzt einen ganz
anderen fundort für das erste
außerirdische leben das wir entdecken
werden er ist davon überzeugt dass wir
es hier im eigenen sonnensystem finden
werden sieben mögliche fundorte nennt er
von dort einst der mars 30 meter unter
der oberfläche könnte es flüssiges
wasser geben und damit primitive
lebensformen genauso könnte es auf dem
pluto seien überall wo es wasser geben
könne es auch mikroben geben sagt rostek
in einem interview mit der website
future allerdings betonte er dass er
damit nichts sagt dass es plutonia geben
würde und drei jupitermonde kommen für
ihn auch in frage europa wo
unterirdische ozeane leben bearbeiten
könnten ganymed der größte mond im
sonnensystem und kallisto wo es wasser
und eine atmosphäre gibt und auch zwei
saturnmonde könnten womöglich leben
ermöglichen
danke an die cassini mission die hier
unglaubliche forschungsergebnisse
geliefert hat titan und enceladus und
bei enceladus könnte es besonders
einfach sein leben zu finden
dadurch dass der mond mit seinen
geysiren wasser in den weltraum schießen
braucht man nicht zu bohren
sondern es reicht proben im auswurf der
geysire zu nehmen und zu erde zu fliegen
und hier zu analysieren aber schafft
sagt glaubt auch an die baldige
entdeckung von intelligenten aliens er
geht davon aus dass wir es in den
nächsten 20 jahren finden
es gebe da draußen eine billion galaxien
jede mit einer billion planeten die
leute auf der erde müssten schon sehr
speziell sein wenn es da draußen nicht
intelligentes leben geben würde wenn er
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit aliens der erste
kontakt da geht es darum ob wir nicht
schon längst kontakt zu außerirdischen
haben eine absurde vorstellung also bis
dann bleibt dran